Jason I know we spoke about this the
last event extensively but one question
I didn't get to ask you is what did you
learn about the whole situation with the
hunt back in the fall that you might
apply to future marketing efforts or any
of your films in general well I've
learned a lot of things I mean the first
thing I learned is if you have a movie
that's tough to explain in a 90 second
trailer it's good to show it so the
second time that we released the movie
we've shown it to all the all the media
before before they saw the trailer so
people can talk about something they've
seen versus what they haven't seen and
then you know you just have to be in
today's we're all you have to be very
very careful about about what's in your
initial marketing materials and result
though I'm very very satisfied the end
result two viewings now it's very very
well thought-out especially when you go
back around and you know where it ends
I'm not gonna get into spoilers just yet
but for you like what was your first
impression of the script when you read
it and of that character in particular
my first impression of the script is
that Jason Blum is going to be subject
to a 5150 involuntary mental hold that's
the truth his mind that's true and but
then as I kept reading the script and I
kept seeing how layered and nuanced
Damon and Nick executed it I got very
very excited then when I found that
Craig Sobel was directing it was a huge
fan of for many years it was just like a
no brainer and I was pushing to to place
that an island and it was just so fun to
to take that character who you kind of
don't know was he good is he bad what's
going on at least I'll be with him for
the whole movie you know maybe not who
knows but it was it was awesome
do you know Staten Island's real name
well initially it was called handle bar
handle bar handle bar and then we
because I was gonna have a big handlebar
moustache
then right that's right we kind of just
crafted to Staten Island I have my
thought it's probably Sal because I
think I read 87% of the people who live
in Staten Island's name is Sal but but
but we just call them stat now so a
spoiler here that we are going to put a
big spoiler warning oh yeah right here a
spoiler it sounds like a very silly
question but I do want to know what is
it like for you in a scene where you
have to play a dead body mmm it was the
first time I've ever died on camera and
I was first I was very nervous that like
I was gonna be dead and the directors
like hey dude your face moves a lot when
you die you know like you open your eyes
and blink alot but it was it was a
pleasure I had sweet little five foot
one amy madigan dragging my 220 pound
ass through the through the store but it
was good I'm looking to play more
corpses miss Furyk dead background a lot
of speaking of all of your movies I was
reading in the notes that a lot of what
they were trying to do with this movie
is make a Jason Blum movie or a Blum
House movie so over the years how is the
definition of a plumb house movie
changed for you and is there kind of a
next chapter of what that movie means to
you I think it's always important for
that I think that should mean it
something different every year I think
you can't lean back and I hate the
notion Hollywood leans back too much on
past successes and tries to repeat them
I really try not to do that but I like
to think our movies are exciting and
subversive and most importantly original
that they feel like different from
what's come before never seen it before
so what what does your mind go through
when you jump into a movie like this
because the first assumption I made
which was not accurate after seeing the
movie is that this can be associated
with something like the purge
specifically as far as franchise goes
now I think that's still very much in
play so what do you think about kind of
the next chapter here or if any like the
core concept can be taken to something
else other than necessarily a matter
date well I think one of the benefits of
low-budget movies is I don't have to
think about that when we're doing our
movies so I always encourage our
filmmakers not
to do what you're doing don't think
about the sequel don't worry about I
always use paranormal activists to
people died at the end of the movie and
it was found footage we figured out a
way to make five more so don't construct
a movie for a sequel construct a movie
that's great and if you want to make it
say we'll figure it out but the cool
thing about this movie is you have that
really interesting applicable concept
that could be applied to it it could
absolutely a gun it could be it could be
it could be a stage show it could be a
ride or it could be more movies for sure
can the hunt be a maze at Halloween
Harnack this is great have you really
ever played a zombie no but I've gone
and scared the hell yeah I want to play
a zombie I could work that out you could
call Donna I would like to go through
that maze and I think the guys on
blockers is grabbing me too
speaking of a Halloween Horror Nights is
that concept suitable for a plum house
movie in the future
yes definitely we've actually talked
about it we've actually talked about it
we've never we haven't quite figured it
out but there's definitely a movie in
Halloween or tonight somewhere it's very
scary if you're shooting the Mindy
project and the noise from Hollywood how
how our nights is blowing your night
maybe that's our most that's the static
scariest ugly line producers mad at me
because we're not able to shoot because
the how horrid eyes make too much noise
that's their first act I feel like
that's the best reason in the world not
to be able to shoot your project yes I
can do you feel about a [ __ ] in general
I always like to hear about if someone
is a horror fan first and foremost
movement sub-genre of [ __ ] speaks to
you the most for me I'm a little more on
the Thriller side of horror than the
kind of supernatural side of horror I'm
kind of one of those people who's like I
need the story to be grounded and based
in reality like I just don't know why I
like like so movies like this or or
movies about like like get out or US
where it's something that could
ostensibly happen that's the one that
keeps me up at night the other stuff I'm
like zombies aren't real I love them but
but what I would call true true horror
have you played the game in your head
though with things like zombie
apocalypses and disaster movies like
will will you survive do you have a
chance Oh a hundred percent survive what
a hundred percent I will survive a
zombie apocalypse
that's true you will he prefers he's
prepared for he's prepared for in real
life yeah it's like a generator in wall
that's a you know what's going down in
his aam be a first guy hit at five
second first guy happened by masks or
anything you have corona every single
horror scenario like in your play view
but I get it out of my I get it out of
my system in my in my job I don't think
it's ever gonna really happen what I
have let's go to my hospital yeah I'm
going to go to you I got meals where
it's got a generator got a generator I
got meals ready to eat 30 years we're
good yeah I mean they're not good
they're like oatmeal and like just yeah
it kind of like cheesy rice but it
sounds like a 10 year olds die and
that's my what are some qualities in the
hunt that you would like to see in more
genre movies out there anytime you can
kind of thrill people and make them
laugh to me that's like them the two
things I look for in a collective
experience at the theater and how
something that's funny it makes you
laugh kind of tricks your brain into
being like oh this is funny and then
some really scary happen so kind of just
making the audience feel bit like
they're on a roller coaster they don't
know what to expect that's what I want
to see in those in those movies you guys
accomplish that here how does Craig kind
of get your in the right headspace to
make sure you're nailing the tone while
you're on set I think you know making
sure that we weren't too broad making
sure we weren't like characters of the
people we were playing and he this is a
very calming nature and he is a great
laugher so I think when you do say
something funny and you get like a good
reaction from your director it's very
encouraging